if you saw the menu then you know that
this movie is nothing if not
unpredictable so it's really no surprise
that we never could have predicted
everything that went into making this
deliciously disturbing film let's take a
look inside the menus menu food was a
very important part of this film right
and it was something the creators knew
they had to get well right so they
called in a professional chef Dominique
kren to help them make the food elements
feel real kren says that they signed on
to help with the movie right after
reading the script because in her words
I felt that I really was a lot like Chef
Julian without the violence kren ran a
kitchen boot camp for the cast who
played slowex kitchen staff the cast was
composed of actors and real life chefs
ultimately kren said the boot camp was a
hundred percent authentic and felt like
a real restaurant opening food is
theater so said the production designer
but he carried on saying food is comedy
food is drama
food is satire the idea that you're
painting that experience with the
structure of a film made perfect sense
to me okay but do you know about the
menu's connection to Chef's Table
Dominique kren wasn't the only
professional from the world of cooking
to help make the menu come to life
Chef's Table is the way so many people
know about the world of cooking if you
saw some similarities between the hit
series and the menu you were definitely
picking up on something the creator of
Chef's Table David Gelb created many of
the shots of the food that made it into
the movie and the director said there's
some of his favorite shots but did you
wonder how they made Hawthorne well a
lot went into making the restaurant at
the heart of the movie what it became
the production designer used many
real-life trendy restaurants as his
inspiration But ultimately though what
the creators imagined Chef slowik's
Vision to be was the restaurant's main
inspiration the creators even took the
look of a church into consideration when
creating Hawthorne which is a nod to
food being the chef's religion so there
was nothing accidental about the
fictional restaurant's specific look and
according to the director there was a
constant translation between my dramatic
storytelling needs the photography needs
of the film and what worked making a
truly realistic high-end restaurant
after all the work that went into making
Hawthorne what it was they were left
with the perfect stage for the chef's
Vision to play out on but how did the
infamous Chef come to be Ray fines had
his work cut out for him when it came to
bringing this unique character to life
while fines called his character a
disturbing figure it was pretty clear
that he was still able to get into his
character's head he worked with
Dominique kren to get the character just
right she explained that it was not
about him understanding how to cook it
was about him understanding the
character what it means to be a chef and
she also says I reminded him that he was
the one in charge the director of this
Symphony your confidence and your intent
density is essential so it's clear that
fines learned quite a bit about the ins
and outs of the kitchen and a lot went
into getting the movie's unique tone a
horror movie a thriller a comedy even a
cooking show getting the tone just right
wasn't easy Nicholas Holt knew this from
his first read of the script truth and
honesty in each individual moment was
his trick to making it work while the
actor Amy Carrero believes that striking
the perfect tone was a result of leaving
lots of room to pick the best moments
when it came time to edit John Leguizamo
said that the director marks incredible
Precision made the tone tick on top of
the combination of these strategies the
cast and crew made sure of one thing
even when the movie felt like a comedy
the food was always serious this
combination of comedy horror satire was
part of what made ray fine sign on to do
the film in the first place okay and
what's the story behind that perfect
cheeseburger if you saw the menu then
you definitely remember that burger
that one one character her freedom and
if you're anything like us that burger
probably had your mouth watering well
like everything else that takes place in
Hawthorne the apparent deliciousness of
that burger was no accident while the
other meals were mostly designed by
Dominique kren and made to look modern
and high-end they called in Chef John
Ben Hayes to make a burger that looked
more as he puts it nostalgic he explains
that when he was younger he learned to
make a process driven burger and was
surprised by just how much love could go
into making a simple meal while he
called on his earlier years as a chef to
pass on the perfect burger making
process to Ray finds he was still
surprised to find out that he was the
Mind behind a burger so delicious
looking that it actually went viral on
the internet so Margot is quite the
unusual character or or as Anya Taylor
Joy puts it Marco is an enigma she
certainly brought quite a bit of mystery
to an already mysterious character and
the cast and crew could clearly tell how
important the famous horror movie Alum
was to their unique ensemble cast while
it is clear that Anya Taylor Joy has
some serious acting chops she was also
able to relate to Margot very heavily in
an interview she explained that whenever
people try to make her feel small or
unworthy I'm a total Narco in those
situations she then explained that she
didn't actually have much experience
with the complicated world of fine
dining but she did have some very fun
homework to prepare her for the role she
says she watched a lot of chef's table
now Nicholas Holt played Tyler and it's
clear that quite a bit went into this
funny yet surprising character as well
Nicholas Holt has gone in depth about
fleshing out his character and it's
clear like the rest of us he was pretty
confused by what exactly was going on in
Tyler's head according to him the menu
was a nice foray into the horror genre
that unlike others didn't require him to
spend too much time acting scared his
co-star Anya thinks that the difference
between Margot and Tyler were vital to
the film so what does one vital scene
look like when broken down director Mark
and actors Anya and Nicholas discussed
the making of an important scene when
the chef gives his restaurant patrons
oil for dipping without the bread they
showed just how many tiny details needed
to be considered to make the movie tick
even down to a lot of work going into
one
tiny screen performances within
performances within pretension and yes
casting the menu was clearly an
important part of the process of getting
the movie Just Right the ensemble cast
was a key ingredient no pun in ended to
perfect the menu and according to Mark
he believes he got really lucky with a
cast who knew exactly how to perfectly
play the unusual tone alright so Elsa is
an important character just like the
others and a lot went into making her
what she was and in turn showing exactly
how the chef runs his restaurant while
amping up the mystery and horror actor
Hong Chao was the key to Bringing Elsa
to life and according to Mark she gave
the character much needed depth so what
went into making the menu's message it's
pretty incredible to imagine someone
coming up with this concept and while
the cast the food and the perfect
cheeseburger all played Major roles in
bringing the movie to life the message
was of the utmost importance the menu's
unique message comes across through a
unique Twist on the horror genre Anya
thinks the movie is entirely different
from the other horror movies out there
and in the the word of the director
beyond the obvious Eat the Rich
commentary what's interesting to me is
an approach that on a more
anthropological level what is in a
person's ego that feeds this increasing
need for exclusivity okay so what did
you think of the menu did seeing how the
movie was made change your views on it
let's talk about it in the comments and
for more videos like this one make sure
to like And subscribe to the things